in a country known for its sluggish
bureaucracy the process to a man the
Constitution seems to be breaking all
the records only a week after put in
surprise announcement that he wants to
change the distribution of power
lawmakers have voted unanimously to
adopt a hastily written draft while
lawmakers will get some more powers like
approving ministers the presidency will
be strengthened to by giving the head of
state more control over the judiciary we
have a presidential Republic and there
is no reason to move to parliamentary
Republic Russia is not only the biggest
country in the world and a great state
but it is also a country that unites
many nations and religions analysts
believe that President Putin is changing
the Constitution to create a way to stay
in power after 2024 but nobody yet
understands how there's a term for
people who try to explain the policies
and plans of Russia's head of state
Kremlinology but Putin's most recent
moves have left all of them guessing
but many believed our first annual
speech that he will step down when its
turn finishes four years from now a week
later some are not so sure
on the day Putin moved to change the
Constitution his ally Prime Minister
Medvedev was replaced by the largely
unknown hat of the tax office Mihal
Misha Steen a few days later he
appointed a new cabinet leaving many
Russians puzzled by the speed in which
these changes are taking place what we
see is the strengthening of presidential
power but we don't see anything to
counterbalance it therefore it seems to
me that out of all possible scenarios
the one we're putting somehow just stays
in power and keeps all this Authority
looks more likely now than it was a week
ago
whatever game of chess Putin is playing
the head of the Constitutional
Commission has denied that he can run
for president again the second
parliamentary hearing to adopt the
amendments will be held on February 11
once Parliament approves them the people
of Russia will get a chance to vote as
well although it's not sure how and if
that outcome will have any impact stop
fasten al Jazeera Moscow